في الجزائر كشفت هيئه دفاعا عن الصحفي
احسان القاضي ومديرا النشر لموقعي راديو
ام مغرب ايميغ جون كشفت عن عرضه امام وكيل
الجمهوريه وذلك بعد ايام من اعتقاله في
الرابع والعشرين من ديسمبر كما تم اغلاق
مقر اذاعه راديو ام وهذا الموقع الاخباري
مير جو الذي يشرف على ادرتهما الصحفيه
احسان القاضي ما يعد الى الوجه ملف حوريه
الصحافه والتعبير في الجزائر اعتقال صحفي
احسان القاضي الذي يوصف باخر منبر اعلامي
مستقل للشغل موقع تواصل الاجتماعي كذلك
اثر اهتمام الصحافه الدول
الان من المدينه
رحمون نائب رئيس الاتحاد الدولي لحقوق
الانسان اهلا وسهلا بك وسعد عيسى رحمون
نتوقف معك عند قضيه وملف الصحفيه احسان
القاضي الذي عرض اليوم على وكيل الجمهوريه
السؤال الذي
يطرح بالحاح منتهى الموجهه الى هذا الصحفي
الذي يوصف باخر منبر اعلامي مستقل في
الجزائر
[موسيقى]
ماشي شكرا على الاستضافه يبدو ان قضيه
القاضي احسان النبي هو الصحفي وطبعا مسير
لي
راديو ان وماجوج انرجون
بالطبع الذين هم اخر منبر بحريه التعبير
وحوريه الصح
ابي تعود قريته الى ثلاث سنوات ايات انه
ليس عنده قضيه واحده يتم حاليا
حيث بدات المضايقات على الصحفي وعلى
صحفي المجرب من ثلاث سنوات يجب ان نذكر ان
خالد الضررني ايضا تم اعتقاله وتنزل خطوه
والعتيد من صحفيين همم
اجركم لا يمكن ان اقول لكم ما هي المواجهه
اليه حاليا همم لانني لا ما هي التهم وحسب
المعلومات التي وصلتنا من هيئه دفاعه همم
تهامه بالنسبه لعمله الصحفي من مناسبه همم
ادائه لعمله الصحفي وايضا الحاله الاداريه
لربما بالنسبه لنظام تزعج همم النظام
الجزائري يرجو ان همم فيجب ان نذكر ايضا
ان هناك ثقيله وجهت له في الماضي وتعلق
اساسا بماده 87 مكرره من قانون العقوبات
التي تم ادراجها في قانون العقوبات همم
الحراك همم ثوره الحراش الجزائري فهذه
التربه لا تتعلق اساسا ارهابيه فهل يمكن
ان نتصور ان صحفي او مناضل حقوق او مناضل
سياسي برايه
بالنسبه
المكرمه
والصحافه همم
وعلى مدى سنوات 30 الماضيه كانت هناك
استقلاليه في هذا المجال الى ما يعذر ربما
هذا الاستهداف لرموز الاعلام والصحافه من
المستقلين منهم
يعني همم
بينما كانت هناك نوع من تسامح فلا يجب ان
ننسى قضيه محمد قناه الذي توفي في السجن
هو صحفي لا يمكن ان ننسى ايضا العديد من
الصحفيين الذين دخلوا السجن بالنسبه
لمناسبه اداء
كسحافيين ولكن همم
الاحتيارات الشعبي وبعد الوجوه رئيس
الدوله الحالي الى همم
المراديه او قصر الرئاسه في الجزائر فان
ااه النظام زاد الشحنه على
الصحفيين الذين لا يدخلون في خط النظام في
خط
النظام الجزائري
الطرح السياسيه
كيف
تتوقعون ربما سير هذه القضيه ونعلم ان
ربما بعض الامور العامه التي لا تزال غامض
ربما في طريقه في طريقه همم تكوين وهمم
بلوره العهده الثانيه هي همم رئيس الدوله
فتوقع ان يكون المزيد من الاعتقالات
بالنسبه للصحفيين والمنقاء لانهم لا
يريدون اي راي المخالف بالنسبه للعهده
الثانيه التي ينظمها
النظام الحالي
شكرا لك استاذ عيسى رحمه نائب رئيس
الاتحاد الدولي لحقوق الانسان حدثنا من
مدينه الفرنسي